PUT-BACK.
3 FOR 1.
BUT IT WAS ANNOUNCED BEFORE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT WAS MADE.
HOLIDAY AGAIN WITH A BEAUTIFUL
MOVE.
WENT TO THE LEFT HAND.
>> Reggie: AGAIN.
THAT IS TWICE WITH THE FINISH
WITH THE LEFT.
>> Marv: IT'S REALLY UNUSUAL,
ISN'T IT, REGGIE?
HE IS BASICALLY A RIGHTY AND
DRIBBLES WITH THE RIGHT HAND.
ON THE DRIVE, HE GOES TO THE
LEFT.
HERE IS YOUNG SHOOTING IT UP FOR
COLLINS!
>> Reggie: THAT WAS A PASS, TOO.
THAT WAS NOT A SHOT THERE BY
TRAE YOUNG.
WOW.
>> Marv: IT'S A FOUR-POINT
ATLANTA LEAD AND LAST TOUCHED BY
CAPELA.
>> Reggie: YOUNG KNEW THAT
COLLINS WAS GOING TO ROLL HARD
ALL THE ALONG.
SO HE THREW THIS ABOVE THE
SQUARE AND LET THE ATHLETICISM
OF COLLINS DO THE REST.
THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL PLAY THERE
BY YOUNG!
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY AN ASSIST.